in this video i'm going to give you
three ways to guarantee that people do
not do what you want them to do
especially employees in a business every
one of us every day has tried to
influence people internally in the
business to do things that we want them
to do we try to influence them with
money we try to influence them with
praise and accolades with a big vision
so that they get internally motivated to
do the stuff but some people don't do it
and so in this video what i want to do
is break down the three best ways to
guarantee that no one does what you want
them to do you can take this process and
you can reverse it if you want them to
do what you want them to do but if we
think about the things that we can do to
get them to not want to do what we want
them to do then it's much funnier from
the top the easiest way to make sure
that they do not do what you want them
to do is don't tell them don't
communicate the expectation don't even
let them know that you want them to do
it if you even do let them know that you
want to do it make sure you don't record
it because if you just say it in passing
or say it on a conversation or a zoom
call and it's not written anywhere you
can still virtually guarantee that
they're not going to do it especially if
you don't repeat it don't ask about it
frequently one line item on a quarterly
report that happens versus you checking
in twice a day about a statistic like if
you do that they're definitely gonna
think it's important so don't do that
just trying to ask for it as
infrequently as possible even so not
even give them the metric to track so
that's number one number two is make
sure they don't know how to do it so if
you want them to do something give them
the task that's clearly communicated you
repeated it you did it in a recorded
fashion you do it frequently in terms of
how frequently asked them but then just
make sure they don't know how to do it
it's the best way to set them up to fail
don't train them around what you want
them to do in general don't train them
on how to prioritize their time so that
they can get it done given their
workload and then also make sure that
you don't tell them how you specifically
like it done because everybody has
preferences right just make sure you
don't train them on any of those things
first two items in the triangle alex is
how to make sure people don't do what
you want them to do triangle the third
piece of this triangle all right this is
this is a killer motivation
we want to make sure that they are as
unmotivated as humanly possible and
maybe even ideally motivated or
incentivized to not do it a couple ways
you can do that is one don't pay them or
directly compensate them for doing it
number two you want the work to feel as
pointless as possible you want them to
feel like they're digging a hole only to
push the dirt back in at the end of the
day and then have no one there to even
see that they did it you want to
definitely not praise them for digging a
good hole and then not actually show
them that that hole is how you lay pipe
how you lay electrical lines to turn a
building on geez i'm just i'm just
killing it right now you don't want to
show how it benefits other people that
they care about within the company so
for example if i said hey john i need
you to put the call notes in from your
sales call because susie in finance it
makes her life five times harder to have
to go through all this stuff and she
can't be with her kid because she's
working overtime taking all these calls
trying to glean all this data going
through customer support logs to fill in
the blanks that you could do in five
minutes and i know that you're the type
of person so we went from purpose other
people they care about so now we're
gonna talk about their own self-interest
which is like i know you're the type of
person who is honest right of course
well you wouldn't promise something
that's not real right okay well what
you're doing right now you might not
know it is that you're not giving us the
notes to actually fulfill the promises
you're making so i peel the values and
then you can also appeal to
self-interest in the most tangible way
you make more money by doing this when
you do this thing it actually helps us
sort through the applications so you can
close a higher percentage of people at
higher prices so you make more money per
hour if you take these five minutes does
that make sense cool and on top of that
there's a little nugget on your bonuses
according to making sure that you fill
out call notes for over 95 of sales
calls if we did that we'd have a high
likelihood that they would do it so you
want to reverse that whole equation when
you're thinking about having a lens
through which to have the conversation
with somebody who's not doing the things
that you want them to do this is how i
would approach it this is the scripting
i got this from layla all kudos go to
her she has a great youtube channel you
should check it out is say hey
johnny it's not like you to not attend
to the details is it that you didn't
know you don't know how or is it that
you don't want to one we protected the
person's ego because we said it's not
like you so i'm not attacking you i'm
attacking the activity it's this tiny
little shift that makes this
conversation so much easier then you
give them a context through which that
they can reply is it that you didn't
know i didn't tell you i didn't record
it i didn't talk about it frequently and
i didn't give you the metrics is that
what it is or is it that training-wise i
didn't train you on how to do it how i
want you to do it and how to do it
within the context of your larger
workload or is it the things that i just
covered with motivation motivation and
training i stole from andy grove
ruthlessly the founder of intel and he
wrote a book called high output
management recommended a little bit
advanced and in that book he says the
job of the boss is two things to
motivate and train in his mind he said
either someone doesn't want to do it or
they don't know how to do it i add in
the third piece which is that they
didn't know that you wanted to to begin
with which i think happens a lot and so
that has given birth to the acquisition
triangle of how to get people to not do
the things that you want them to do on
the flip side you can reverse those
things and make sure that you set
expectations you record it you talk
about it frequently you give them the
metrics to talk about it about train
them on how to do it you train them how
you prefer they do it and then you train
them on how to do it within the context
of the larger workload they have and
then you motivate them from a global
level of how this feeds the business the
other people that care about employees
on how it impacts their life in a
railway how it's going to help the
customer and their experience from a
values perspective you are this way and
by doing this you are aligning with
these values that are true to you and
then finally you will align to their
pocketbook hey and if you do these
things you can get a 500 bonus right or
a thousand orders whatever it is keeping
awesome mozy nation i love you all don't
deserve you
keep being great see in the next one bye